hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night I'm
here with my two best buddies that ones
Billy and that one's Joey
Billy and Joey and I hope they die in a
fire cuz I actually hate him okay
so I think there was an uh anyway I
think there was another door wasn't
there another door around here I gotta I
gotta figure out where it was tell you
what
amnesia husband okay
I like glanced up and I saw human
figures I was like wait a minute and
then I go then I remembered it was just
stupid
never mind okay that's done
warning can cause yeah so there's
another there's another way through
somewhere I just can't remember where
what the hell is that blocked Oh poop
yeah that ways locked up I don't think
this key goes back I think I probably
have to go through the portal again
yeah yeah yeah
okay Betty alright so I'm gonna go
through the portal again unless there
was something down here but I don't
think there was go through the portal
hey Billy hey Joey
oh you're not Billy doing unless you are
so if I go dissin way I might just get
to some I might just get to something
that I can't
ow my ow okay so down here was where I
did the puzzle but there was no other
door oh yeah of course of course it was
this at the top of the stairs here
that's it I'm I'm an idiot guy you think
I mean I only go a few days before
between plays through so you'd think I'd
be able to get these pretty quickly but
nope I'm an idiot
I'm just a big doofus can't do anything
right anyway hopefully this next puzzle
won't take me so down
oh one guy asked how can I constantly do
or let's plays and he's asked if the
[ __ ] dies down after a bit and um in a
way it does because well let me just
take a moment to explain the thing about
amnesia is the game is built with
certain mechanics that play on certain
fears but and well before I say the
button and people who just try to
imitate amnesia and the way that amnesia
scared you will find that it's it kind
of dulls it down a bit what's great
about custom stories is that people find
new ways to scare you the original
amnesia didn't have mannequins well I
mean they had those statute but they
were never used in the ways that people
used them and that's why I have such a
giant phobia of mannequins and if you
want to understand why I do check out my
nightmare house let's play check out my
highlights of lacasa
ah oh la caza and I think abduction had
one too
I'm not mistaken those both had really
good ones Oh God
ah
where am I where did I go look at nice
day I don't have any oil
give me some sanity why am I going slow
why do I have so many questions
oh I'm up here you can't hurt me it was
a monster I heard it okay fake hello hi
the machine has been leaking oil so we
had to shut it down somehow the pipes
were broken out I've been hearing noises
in the halls and there was a loud clunk
I didn't know if you get there right um
I've been hearing noises in the hall
tonight I get the feeling something is
going to happen but we're going to shut
this place down soon so it will be fine
okay
man I was just talking about new ways to
scare people and people when people come
up with stuff like this and everything
else that has been done it oh it's
twitching and everything else that has
been undone in this mod the scares will
never end and yes
[ __ ]
what is this room key eight okay there
number two uh and yes I was saying for
it does it is hard to keep playing for
our games for more than one reason I
will need a saw to get the wood down
lime use the crowbar before but sure saw
whatever oh man
like no joke it can be all this working
then ok Lane like no joke
yeah like playing horror games it's fun
and I love to do it for you guys by the
old ticker needs a break every now and
then I'm there
[Music]
seven don't tell me this is something
I'm gonna be down here for days if this
is just a gigantic room with 80 doors
that I all I have to go in every one of
them good thing I know my no man rumor
Roman numerals sorry about that
I went stupid this is the door was
Justin all right I don't know I don't
know I don't care I want to find these
doors I want to get out of here I only
merrily I only have the key to room
eight so I need to find room eight five
need to find a way to get this fixed
maybe some oil some oil yeah
like the note said get some oil that's
okay I'm gonna go down this hallway
Check Into the doors oh man
see this is the beauty of this mod this
guy knows how to put more content into
it use the environments like it's a
simple room and people have made rooms
bigger than this but eight doors
probably I get the key for one door ah
here we go number eight for one
oh it was a dog
Oh something was scratching at my door
my mom left one of the dogs here and is
scratching at my door house what the
hell is that I've never heard it before
Oh ma'am okay we're maid and not the
dachshund Doc's window or anyway let's
go in here I'm installing anyway content
key one key eight doors stop it charlie
charlie just lots of code oh don't tell
me again oh oh
oil beautiful oil if you need to put a
jar under the oil leak just use the key
on the table to get in my room to get to
the key to the chest but remember to
return the key to the room where I had
the key that you needed the key to get
into when you're done good luck oh and
[ __ ] you cuz I hate you with those
instructions I could have had the key
here but screw you buddy it's great all
right whatever so I need to go to a room
from one well I mean I are immersing
room two
but it's a mystery where this could be
how long was I wandering around how long
was i wandering run in the darkness ah
here's from one before I noticed the
bodies like how many bodies I just
walked past far so good
and that seems normal
arms in like that there sure seem to be
a lot of body parts and dead people for
a guy that was trying to resurrect the
dead there shortly ah no not today
you're a dick Oh close close
did he just close the door
oh he closed the door just so he could
bash it down nobody likes you nobody
likes you
there's anybody out there like him
anybody better not like no no no no no
if I hear one person out there likes me
excommunicated ran from my channel
that's not even a thing but uh I'll
figure it out I'll call YouTube up on
their YouTube hotline uh what are you
doing
swung at the door that wasn't there go
away go away and die in a fire please
thank Jah
you're still there why are you still
there
well that's probably why because you got
stuck on something the same thing I got
stuck on but whatever I got the key to
the chest and roommate man okay rub
eight rooms keys to each one and then
you have to find a key to a chest from
one room to another where was it
it was fast here yeah it was past here
then I went around this way round
no ah come on oh right here that's good
good
gotta gotta gotta go yeah okey-dokey
there's nothing in here
oh there's okay thank goodness ah jars
not in here where is it
damn a day Yuma I'll have to find it
somewhere up here okay a few drops yeah
there's still some oil in there good
oh I know the board's the saw for the
board's that's right that's right now I
just got to find the boards
where was the boards that were near here
pores there we go oh yeah get to work
that man I don't think you used that saw
correctly I'm pretty sure that wouldn't
happen can't clear this out because I'm
counting on a monster coming by I don't
need this thank you hell is that
sorry I had plus one a jar breaking it
causes other jars in the area to break
as well so skilled amnesia RPG why is it
stuck
why is that we're stuck I said we're not
moving it's moving pixel-by-pixel there
we go
there's nothing in it ah it could have
been a rewarding but no
okay
hello and ah that's what I'm in here for
pink room key which one rum rum six okay
nobody nobody's gonna jump out in bug me
turn o room six by room three that's
right I'm sick by room three man this is
gonna take me forever
wait no crap
wait crap oh no here yeah room six okay
room six is gonna have to wait so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I don't like my train of
thought how can I do this I've done this
four hundred times or so and as always I
will see you in the next one bye bye